what is going on guys this is
statistically challenged and today I've
got another video for you guys today I'm
gonna be doing something a little bit
different than I normally do something
I've actually never really done an RS
which I think it's going to make the
video a lot more interesting because I
know a lot of people out there haven't
flipped before today we are gonna be
trying to see how much money we can make
on the grand exchange flipping starting
with exactly 100 mil I'm pretty excited
to start this video because again I
don't know what to expect I mean the
concept the flipping is very simple you
buy stuff for lower and you sell it for
higher not too hard to grasp at the end
of the day guys the whole point of this
video is to challenge myself and see how
much I can make it an hour
hopefully we profit I mean that's the
[__] goal here we have to actually
make money because I know flipping can
be like a bit risky and I am using a
huge cash stack so don't further adieu
let's start this video I have moved the
timer slightly because I just want you
guys to be able to see what I'm typing
in the GE chat we're gonna go into grand
exchange start the timer and I don't
even order start now from the videos
I've watched on YouTube a lot of people
like to do dissolver items we're gonna
start with a magic Fang because this is
a relatively cheap one to see the
margins right you just buy it and sell
it and what the [__] wait that doesn't a
hundred came urgent ok how much did I
buy for again two four four five K
alright and we're gonna leave those in
and we're gonna move right to another
item we're gonna go for the dragon boots
now because they are economy's PvP item
buy a lot of Mane's so they have a 2k
margin I feel like that's actually not
bad ok so we just put the offer in for
30 dragon boots I was excited to try
some Third Age items but it is only an
hour and only like 20-30 H items are
traded a date alright guys so we have
some offers and now we're gonna do the
Berserker rings the dark bow the Dee
boots I mean these are all buying the
magic things right now aren't actually
buying so I'm gonna bought that one
we're gonna put in the dark bows I can't
buy too much it because it don't forget
the prices the dark bows had a decent
margin of like yeah that's like a
[__] 11 K margin not too bad man the
Berserker rings as well had a decent
margin it's actually not that bad it's
14k but you know anything we can flip
for 14k in like one minute is actually
not bad
yeah so as you guys can see the Dee
boots are doing quite nice right now
the berserkering instantly sold the rest
of the Dee boots
this is what I like to see when like
shits actually selling quite fast right
guys so I'm gonna put the dark bows in
for a little lower they don't actually
see me buying all those berserk rings
just sold all right all the berserk
rings just came in guys as you can see
we're buying them for 2.5 ml 6 K and
we're selling them for 2.5 million K
which is actually quite a decent margin
considering we're gonna flip six of them
so that's gonna be like almost 100 K
just from the berserk rings right there
these Debose are gonna have to go we're
gonna put them in for 430 k the margins
gonna be quite low but it's just a 5k
margin for 10 so it's gonna be 50 K
right there the berserkering seems to be
coming in really quickly so we're gonna
buy more of those alright so for now
we're doing pretty well but the problem
is that I just have this big fat cash
stack in my inventory and I feel like um
you know wasting potential not having it
in sway should really need to buy stuff
that's the challenge of merchandise many
items you got to keep track of reading
Berserker necklaces a lot of OBP carries
out there just could have potential to
have a decent margin
yeah that's a 70k margins we're
definitely gonna use that okay we're
gonna get a water berserker net this is
here because as we love that margin
everyone put 15 all the dragon boots
sold again guys the dragon boots are
really nice the dark bows are not
selling for some reason I don't know why
oh yeah when the [__] did a dark boat
only cost 400 30k jesus [__] christ
okay right as I said that one of them
sold okay all the D boots just sold
again nice just passed the 10-minute
mark guys I feel pretty good about this
you know for not having merged on this
game like ever before I think we're
doing pretty well
another Darko just sold nice so they
seem to be selling it 433 K now or 430 K
now drop the price for 3 K manage its
selling I'm gonna abort the rest of the
dark bows and just sell off these 7th
and Berserker rings as well I think I
might have hit the cap on berserk rings
I'm not sure so we're just gonna sell
off this one again there you go instant
flip on that preserving 17 K made just
like that I think 20 is the d boot cap
so we're just gonna abort that as well
alright guys so as you guys can see now
we've got the archer rings and G they're
going quite quick as you can see the
margins pretty good we also check the
stuff the dead margin and poke those art
rings just sold and two more just bought
yeah this is really quick I put in an
offer for some dragon square shields and
as you can see these our trains are just
buying and selling like [__] crazy
but once we hit the cap we axe
won't be able to buy any more of these
none of the berserk rings have bought
and none of this stuff the dead saps the
debts of bub but as we can see the
margin on that is huge plus the dark
bows okay as I [__] say this one
sells but they are not selling quick at
all I'm also gonna check in an offering
for the dragon train bodies cuz why the
[__] not a little update one berserk
necklace finally bought the dark bows
still not all sold the berserk necklace
is in is you can see that margins pretty
nice a dragon dream body just bought as
well these have about a 20k margin as
you guys can see so we're gonna try to
sell this one off see what happens we
have a full GE dough so ok the dark
boats just sold nice we're gonna put the
dragon chained body in for that 20k
margin act about a mill and 64k so yeah
update you guys when I'm back big change
in the GE offers guys we've put in some
surf disease we put in some magic bangs
the extra ring we got one more none of
them are buying I think we hit the cap
again on the arch rings the dragon chain
bodies are flipping quite nicely we down
the Berserker necklace 20k because you
know it wasn't selling I just think that
it's an you know an inactive item right
now but we put the magic thanks
hopefully they sell they have a beastly
margin I was doing the one hour
challenge not the five day challenge so
I'm gonna have to abort these because
none of them are selling at all not much
has changed again we're just waiting for
these D plates
I mean D chain bodies to sell and the
Berserker necklace to sell we put in a
40 ml lid of the dams they had a nice
margin it was like 40k but yeah guys
it's just a bunch of waiting for the
most part but um you know I am quite new
at this and I don't know the hot items
but I'm trying my best boys okay so I
put an offer in for all these dragon
bones and they all bought at two three
nine nine as you can see they have a 10
GP marker I'm gonna stick them in the g4
to 407 see if they'll sell they should
go pretty fast though I'm just trying to
you know do something with a smaller
priced item right so all the D bones
just sold and we are trying a new items
you can see the D bones went for a nice
margin we made like 20k there so the
uncharged toxic Trident is our new item
it has a nice margin that is a hundred
and thirty-five K we're gonna buy bunch
of these and so you can make Bank off
these
I don't know where does this be neck
just won't seem to sell I thought there
were so many ah BP carriers out there we
have the occult sir doing pretty I set
around
I think that's an 8k margin see I knew
item we're doing the heavy ballista we
actually bought one uncharged toxic
trident as you can see and now we're
selling it look at that margin boys
that is [__] epic yes this is exactly
went on to see just sold for 2.7 million
and as you can see we bought it for 2.5
mill so a couple minutes have passed the
heavy ballistas are in selling we're
trying triton of the Seas one just
bought we put the magic things back in
to play the lottery and we have two
other uncharged toxic tried and selling
right now and the berserk necklace is
still not buying just what I like to see
both uncharged dragons just sold there
and yeah so we just made 200 and like
20k plus they're pretty [__] nice and
now we have full G es are just waiting
on something I'm gonna board the
ballistas though because they don't seem
to be you know flowing as smooth as I
thought okay guys so it's been about 10
minutes now much has changed as you can
see I put a few offers in for some
high-priced items at about 3 percent
lower just to try to get lucky but I've
been making Bank off the uncharged toxic
Trident so far I sold off the Berserker
necklace I actually dumped it for like
3k higher than what I bought so we still
made 2 K on it but yeah at the end of
the day we lost money because we still
have to check the margin and hopefully
some of this stuff does sell off we also
put the hobby miles in because they had
a nice merchant like 5k or something
alright so guys look at the diagonal
bones 3k margin I actually don't believe
the really k margin I'm buying 1k right
now and see if any of them come in but I
yeah I aborted all the other offers that
I just had we're gonna put somewhere our
rings in because they were pretty fast
to flip oh my god they just all sold
guys if we can flip these for a 3k
margin even if we can flip these for
like a 2k version we'll make so much
money just off these 1 or just off the
Dagon op bones now since we only have 5
minutes left I decided that I was gonna
put the Dagon of bones in at a 1k margin
this way you know they'd sell faster no
one seems to actually be buying them at
the MoMA
we need to select this Varrick armor set
and the uncharged toxic trident we're
trying to buy some d2 h's I don't know
guys
I just want the other end I think we've
made a lot of money but at this point
I'm just trying to play it safe here
with the Dagon off bow and sell these
off and then I think that's it for the
video holy [__] guys look how many
dagger not bones just sold
we just got eight eight eight K for all
those Dagon odd bones we just sold so
many Dagon out bones
it is absolutely insane boys that was
such a good profit alright so I dumped
the other items and I pretty much aboard
of the Dragon two h's all we need to do
is sell off these last 125 diagonals if
we can't do that by the end of the hour
I'm just going to have to dump them so
that I can make it within the one hour
timer it's been a pretty good flippin
session I think for my first time I hope
we can make at least over 500k my goal
was a mill because we do have such a big
starting cash stack I know most of you
guys that they're gonna be like are
you're such a [__] flipper bro I
couldn't [__] flip away more than you
if I had that cash pile but you know
what it's my first time guys go easy on
me it's just a challenge video alright
so I had to dump the Dagon odd bones as
you can see I stopped the timer one
second too late
roast me in the comments redo vid please
anyways but that is it guys we just
flipped for one hour on the grand
exchange with a 100 mill start how much
money did we make I am actually so
excited to see we didn't break the 1
mill obviously because we don't have a
hundred and one mill but if we put this
into the price checker if we made 915 hi
NK guys for one hour of flipping and I'm
not even that good at it I found some
random guy in FCP and I looked up his
dad's he was a real FTP player and I
just thought I'd be nice and give away
all the profits in this video to him I
mean just look at this guy full Sarah
with the room sim no boots I mean he
does have boots but they're like leather
boots no amulet team cape on dude this
is your standard [__] free-to-play
player he's doing he'll Giants and I
wanted to make a stay so I handed him
the exact amount of profit we made in
this video you know I just felt like
being nice 959 K isn't gonna do me
anything but if I can make someone
else's day man that's all that counts so
as you guys can see arcade is or however
you say it if you're watching is grats
man
the person I saw it you were the biggest
noob i saw out there I hope you get my
resume man if TV sucks but yeah guys if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more content subscribe to my channel
and make sure to check out my other vids
I have a lot of vids that are similar to
the second one our challenges if you
guys want me to do this with a lower
amount of money then just comment it
down below give me some suggestions
leave an honest rating on the video do
all that good stuff
until next time boys